yeah hello when to welcome to this video
playing our moreno in a blitz game i
stopped the recording with that because
i thought he wasn't around i'm trying to
abort the game because I mean he's lost
like one minute 30 but he declined the
board request I usually um suggests that
if someone is down that much on time
because of some misstep or whatever I
don't like to have this time advantage
due to some something bad happening to
tooth opponent so um yeah but he didn't
take it it simply did not accept them
aboard request okay it seems like i'm
getting the bishop pair here for no
particular compensation yeah what has a
exacting the decent um share of space
and so this is may be quite interesting
try to use the development elite here
and yeah okay but now he has to go back
or give me yeah a total bishop pal
mm-hmm remarkable you just place this
position with two bishops against two
nights huh so what now Bishop g4 maybe
rebooting this okay it's got clean air
form hmm ok that wasn't ideal no he's
probably able to play you five next
okay so I'm taking this undo before
winning the B porn oh yes to go to a
form so i know it gives me the pawn ok
we'll take before hmm ok ok ok ok
you
yeah I'm okay i didn't use this opening
play at all probably I mean black shirt
should have been a lot better after
white misplayed that opening so much but
I probably I made some kind of mistake
quite quite get it ok so here I can go
ok 695 bishops III is a double attack I
guess I can do that hmm possibly didn't
see that let this is hanging oh my just
a 4 and I'm do that would have been
better him ok i thought i would material
i didn't see that you're 64 saying
that's awful really awful
so I'm down at the sea pony even though
even though i don't believe that you can
keep it
okay what's this could have just played
rookie tool i'm not sure what he's doing
here okay
very strange maybe I didn't didn't
really see the position correctly I I
don't know i don't understand why he
gave up the exchange okay this is not
easy to win I mean far from that my
structures wrecked really
yeah I go h5 not sure that this leads to
anything and it's got night at five
coming up mmm yeah maybe this is the
only chance but I know I don't think I
can win
with the damaged pawn structure like
that okay yeah the King I cannot cannot
do much now I don't see a way to win I
can probably check in jam here for do a
couple of chicks time Morgan's no real
way forward now I don't think so not
just a draw check check mmm no it's that
way forward somehow i don't i don't see
it I don't see it this way no probably
it's a draw anyway yeah still very weird
that you just gave me the exchange but
maybe I have no winning chances
check check check boys not pressing the
draw button chain one check check check
check game Tehran Joe it's very strange
yes his six is completely ridiculous if
I just play it for my position is
fantastic I just thought I win material
I didn't cod6 this is simple move I
didn't see because here he will lose
stuff because of his bad piece
coordination now something like c 3 i'll
take you for back rank mmm i just
thought i win anyway we'll c 6 and we
have blundered this and now yeah yeah I
simply don't understand why you played
this you can just play up to two now
what is the big deal here instead not
working I know I can take of course
you're sorry so okay we'll see one then
mm-hmm okay yes so that summer I'm not
winning this position which is probably
my bad technical flavored hmm each five
yeah maybe I should go h5 I ok yeah i
should give check probably and now this
yeah if i get an F fight at four then
I'm probably winning hmm yeah i don't
think i can win here anymore this is
this is probably not possible
the only idea that I see is coming
around all the way with the king and it
takes ages okay so yeah I'm better from
this position on because yeah castles is
just a bad move it allows this winning
the bishop there won't be three so I'm
better from this position but I couldn't
really make make much of it I mean
probably better as a strong word because
I mean his busiest pieces are very still
very active and ammonia so it'll shoot
something serious but of course why
displaying them gap you just accept that
blacks has two bishops against two
knives yeah this now yeah I think all
this is fairly logical yeah it was a
good movie cannot take here because of
the ship's III and now just a forward
and basically winning the position and
probably had chances in the ending but I
didn't didn't play that too well okay
well thanks for watching